today's guitar tip is brought to you by
arpeggianto my online music school
specializing in all things that go pluck
to celebrate the new year we're offering
20 off of your first pack of lessons
just use code happy 2022 before the end
of january
hey guys welcome back for another guitar
tip
today's tip is going to be all about
keeping your instruments safe from
damage
and specifically damage due to humidity
you know it's so easy to look at a
guitar and you know it seems solid seems
fine
it's not really susceptible to
temperature or humidity changes but it
is wood it moves and therefore it can
break unfortunately i've had many cracks
in some of my favorite instruments and
it's a real pain so to spare you that
trouble uh this video is going to be all
about why you need to humidify your
guitar
for many years i worked in a music store
that had a really good guitar repair
shop and i even learned to do a couple
good guitar repairs myself but i'll tell
you every single year at the end of
winter we'd have an influx of dozens and
dozens of people coming in saying hey i
don't know what's wrong my guitar is all
buzzy or hey my my bridge is coming off
my instrument or my bridge came off the
instrument or i have a crack in the top
of my guitar what happened i don't know
what i don't know what the problem is
and the problem always was that that
person didn't humidify their guitar now
i'm in the midwest so we have super dry
super cold winters so depending on where
you are this might be relative to your
climate but essentially the rule is if
you're below 40 or above 60 humidity you
have to be a little bit worried about
the longevity and the safety of your
instruments and luckily it's actually
pretty easy and affordable to make sure
that this doesn't happen to you so
essentially what happens is that wood
contracts or expands depending on the
amount of moisture in the air and if
your guitar was built to be in that
window of 40 to 60 humidity which is
about normal
and suddenly it's exposed to 20 humidity
that radical shock can make the wood
crack and even if the wood doesn't crack
what often happens on guitars is that
when the instrument gets super dry and
the wood contracts the bridge sinks down
a little bit and that means that the
strings sink down a little bit
causing the instrument to be suddenly
buzzy when it wasn't before other things
that might happen is while the wood is
changing size the glue can break and
maybe the bridge comes off sometimes the
top rips off or the braces on inside the
sound hole might come loose and cause
buzzing so i hope now i've scared you
enough to want to humidify your guitar
luckily this is pretty easy and cost
affordable so let's go through some
quick ways that you guys can be
humidifying and protecting your
instruments
now one of the first things you can do
is have a solid case now this is
actually my baroque guitar case so it's
a little bit smaller but it's the same
idea there are cases for your
instruments or guitars that have a wood
lining inside and so this is a really
good way to trap the humidity inside the
instrument and create a little
quarantined area that is very safe
a gig bag is too flimsy it won't it
won't hold in the humidity but a hard
shell case
will now inside i have these little
packs humapax humidifying packs these
are by a company called boveda
i'm not sponsored by them i just use
these because they work really well
there's a lot of companies that make
little packs like this you can put right
inside your your case
this is the same company who makes uh
huma packs for cigar boxes and things um
and on the label it says 49
uh two-way humidifier so why i love
these is because basically you put these
in your case and you're done if there's
too much moisture it'll
suck the moisture out and get it back to
49 if there's too little moisture and
it's too dry it'll it'll regulate it
back to 49 so whether it's too humid or
not humid enough it gets you back to 49
i have two in the case just to make sure
it does the job
uh and it seems to so these are really
cool and easy to use i bought a bunch of
these and i have them in all my cases
it's also super important that you then
leave your case closed this only works
if you have a quarantined environment
but then your case is always this
beautifully 49 preserved humidity in
there
so leave the guitar in its case when
you're not using it and have the hemopax
in there some companies also have
hemopacts that go in these little cloth
bags that even drop in between the
strings so they drop in the sound hole
that's another good option i might even
have another one in the headstock
compartment just to make sure that that
case is totally quarantined for a diy
solution
my luthier friends the brene showed me
this little trick they took a film
canister cut some holes in it and on the
inside there is a sponge so you just
have to wet the sponge
and then put in the film canister and
then throw that in your case
just make sure the sponge isn't dripping
water everywhere but in this one you
have to refill the sponge uh sometimes
once a day
if it's very dry
then some other companies like planet
waves make this one which i used for a
long time
this is
a the same idea as the film canister
but this is made to drop down between
your strings so that goes right in there
and this is basically the same thing you
open it up
and on the inside there is a
sponge but i really had to fill this up
so often i love the huma packs because
you just throw it in there and you
forget about it
i also found these very helpful this is
a digital hygrometer a hygrometer
measures the humidity in the air it also
tells me the temperature and i have the
one of these in my office and i also
have a few of these in some of my cases
um but a little warning uh digital
hygrometers are known to be
pretty inaccurate
sometimes more than ten percent uh i
went to a luthier who had a really good
um actual i don't know if you call it an
analog hygrometer but one that was
calibrated and worked and i just
measured it to this and this was 10 low
and so now i know it's just a little
it's usually 10 lower than the actual
humidity but it's in the ballpark
and it's better to know a general idea
of where you are so if this thing ever
says you know 20
or 15 percent i know it's very dry and
it seems to be pretty accurate for that
now here in my home office my solution
is to actually just have a humidifier
going in my room so that when the
instruments are out they're also you
know at a nice humidity and for that i
have this big guy
just a big tower which i fill up with
water and then it mists out of the top
and within a few hours of this thing
running i can easily get the room to 50
so like i said i really do consider this
a public service announcement please do
yourself a favor and humidify your
precious guitars so thanks so much for
watching i really hope you found this
tip useful i have lots of other guitar
tips you can check out here on youtube
and if you want to see a lot of extra
guitar tips which are only available for
my patrons head over to my patreon where
you can do a very minimal pledge per
month and get access to a lot of behind
the scenes content extra digital
downloads and insight into the classical
guitar course that i'm working on
so stay tuned for more and i'll see you
guys next time
[Music]
you